this was the view recorded on body
cameras worn by the two officers in the
driver and passenger seat of a police
car when they received this call she's
in his white Chevy s-10 possibly has a
knife and gun in his vehicle when they
spotted that truck this happened as the
man drove off a chase began a few
seconds later this I think he's got a
guns as the officer and the officer
driving opens fire through his own
windscreen through a busy residential
neighborhood on a Saturday morning
a chase and the shooting continues the
second officer reaches for a rifle the
shots striking the suspect when he
stopped the firing continues Elias Nava
was later pronounced dead in hospital
police had fired 76 shots in two and a
half minutes and what officers thought
was a handgun turned out to be an air
pistol the officer who was driving has
now been sacked his overall performance
fell far short of the standards the
community and the police department
expects prosecutors say the officer's
actions were alarming and irresponsible
but because they reasonably feared for
their lives they won't face any charges
reigniting that debate in communities
across America about how much use of
force by police is too much Greg Milam
Sky News Los Angeles